AND UNSEEN SEGMENT.
BUT FIRST, UNBRIDLED POWER OF
THE SURVEILLANCE STATE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WAS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN --
COMPRISED OF PRIVATE CITIZENS
SURVEILLED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
WAS INFORMATION COLLECTED AND
THEN RETAINED ABOUT THEM?
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
SHOULD FRIGHTEN EVERY AMERICAN
NO MATTER WHAT YOUR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
WAS THE GOVERNMENT SPYING ON
ITS CITIZENS?
WELL, WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT
CARTER PAGE ON THIS PROGRAM
EARLIER IN WEEK WAS TARGETED
AND SURVEILLED BY THE F.B.I.
HE WAS APPROACHED BY AN F.B.I.
INFORMANT WHO WAS REPORTEDLY
SENT OUT TO MAKE CONTACT WITH
PAGE AND OTHER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AIDES.
THE BIG QUESTION, DID
PRESIDENT OBAMA OR
HIGH-RANKING WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS KNOW OF, AND
AUTHORIZE SPYING ON A
POLITICAL OPPONENT?
MAINLY, TRUMP AND HIS CAMPAIGN
STAFF.
WELL, THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT
THE FIRST TIME THE GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLED CITIZENS OR
CAPTURED INFORMATION ON THEM.
I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO A
HEARING FROM 2013 WHEN SENATOR
RON WIDEN POSED THIS -- RON
WYDEN POSED THIS QUESTION TO
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JAMES CLAPPER.
>> I WANT TO SEE IF YOU CAN
GIVE ME A YES OR NO ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION.
DOES THE N.S.A. COLLECT ANY
TYPE OF DATA AT ALL ON
MILLIONS OR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS?
>> NO, SIR.
>> IT DOES NOT?
>> NOT WITTINGLY.
>> Laura: THEN YESTERDAY,
CLAPPER APPEARED ON "THE VIEW"
WHERE HE TRIED TO DEFEND
HIMSELF AGAINST TRUMP CHARGES
THAT HE IS BASICALLY JUST A
LIAR.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS CALLING ME
A LYING MACHINE.
WELL, OKAY.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT THAT STEMS FROM IS AN
EXCHANGE I HAD WITH SENATOR
WYDEN FIVE YEARS AGO IN MARCH
OF 2013 ABOUT SURVEILLANCE
PROGRAM AND HE WAS ASKING ME
ABOUT ONE AND I WAS THINKING
ABOUT ANOTHER.
SO, I MADE A MISTAKE.
BUT I DIDN'T LIE.
THAT IS WHAT OCCASIONED --
>> Laura: YEAH.
OCCASIONED THE LIE.
WELL, EVEN MEGAN McCAIN
COULD SEE THROUGH CLAPPER'S
OFFISCATION.
>> IN 2013 WHEN YOU WERE ASKED
ABOUT IT YOU SAID NO.
THAT IS A LIE.
>> NO, IT ISN'T.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> WHAT IS HE THINKING ABOUT?
IT'S A LIE.
IT AMAZES ME THAT HE CONTINUES
TO GO ON NATIONAL TV AND
SHAMELESSLY WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE DENY WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW
TO BE TRUE.
INFORMATION LEAKED BY EDWARD
SNOWDEN, THE NATIONAL SECURITY
CONTRADICTS CLAPPER'S CLAIMS.
THE QUESTION FROM WYDEN WAS
SIMPLE AND CLEAR.
WYDEN HIMSELF CALLED OUT
CLAPPER FOR THIS REPEATEDLY.
I THINK THE MOST DAMNING
MOMENT OF "THE VIEW"
APPEARANCE IS THIS ONE.
>> WAS THE F.B.I. SPYING ON
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING ON -- A TERM
I DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE ON
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WERE THE
RUSSIANS INFILTRATING TRYING
TO GAIN ACCESS AND LEVERAGE.
>> I LIKE HOW HE DOES THIS.
SPYING.
LIKE HE DOESN'T LIKE THE TERM.
HE IS THE MAN WHO OVERSAW
MASSIVE SURVEILLANCE AND INTEL
COLLECTED BY SPIES.
HE HAS A PROBLEM WITH THE TERM
"SPYING"?
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THE LAUGHING MAKING IT VERY
BELIEVABLE.
NONE OF THIS WAS LOST ON THE
PRESIDENT WHO TODAY TWEETED
"SPYGATE" COULD BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST POLITICAL SCANDALS IN
HISTORY.
THEN HE DOUBLED DOWN.
>> President Trump: IF YOU
LOOK AT CLAPPER, HE SORT OF
ADMITTED THEY HAD SPIES IN THE
CAMPAIGN YESTERDAY
INADVERTENTLY BUT I HOPE IT'S
NOT TRUE.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS.
WE NOW CALL IT "SPYGATE."
YOU'RE CALLING IT "SPYGATE."
A LOT OF BAD THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> Laura: BAD THINGS,
MR. PRESIDENT, HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING FOR SOME TIME NOW.
REMEMBER WHEN CLAPPER AND
SALLY YATES WERE CONFRONTED BY
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY ABOUT
THE UNMASKING OF TRUMP
OFFICIALS?
THEY WERE SURVEILLED,
REMEMBER, AT TRUMP TOWER.
>> MR. CLAPPER, DID EITHER OF
YOU REQUEST THE UNMASKING OF
MR. TRUMP, HIS ASSOCIATES OR
ANY MEMBER OF CONGRESS?
>> YES.
IN ONE CASE I DID.
I CAN SPECIFICALLY RECALL BUT
I CAN'T DISCUSS IT FURTHER
THAN THAT.
>> DID EITHER OF YOU EVER
REVIEW CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN
WHICH MR. TRUMP, HIS
ASSOCIATES OR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS HAD BEEN UNMASKED?
>> OH, YES.
>> YOU HAVE?
CAN YOU GIVE US DETAILS HERE?
>> NO, I CAN'T.
>> MISS YATES, HAVE YOU?
>> YES, I HAVE.
NO, I CAN'T GIVE YOU DETAILS.
>> Laura: THERE IS LITTLE
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED AN OUTRAGEOUS ABUSE
OF OUR INTEL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
NOT BECAUSE BRENNAN OR COMEY
OR CLAPPER WERE CONVINCED THAT
RUSSIA WAS RIGGING THE
ELECTION.
BUT BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
HOBBLE A MUCH BIGGER THREAT.
DONALD TRUMP.
THE OBAMA CROWD WAS SO BRAZEN
AND SO CONFIDENT THAT THEY
WERE DOING THE RIGHT THING I
THINK IN THE END THEY WERE
REALLY SLOPPY.
AT LEAST SERVE TRUMP
ASSOCIATE -- SERVE TRUMP
ASSOCIATES ARE SUSPECTED OF
BEING YOU ARE VAILED.
BANNON, CONAN, JARED KUSHNER,
CARTER PAGE, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT FOUR TOP
OBAMA OFFICIALS REQUESTED THAT
THE NAMES OF AMERICANS BE
UNMASKED.
FOR SAMANTHA POWER THIS WAS
REPORTEDLY NEAR DAILY
UNDERTAKING IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
THAT YEAR.
2016.
HERE IS WHY ALL THIS DEEP
STATE INTRIGUE MATTERS.
THE OBAMA TEAM HAD A MATERIAL
INTEREST IN SPIKING THE
HILLARY CLINTON E-MAIL PROBE
AND MAKING WAY FOR THE TRUMP
THEIR CAREERS AND THEIR
LEGACIES HUNG IN THE BALANCE.
AS ANDY McCARTHY OF
"NATIONAL REVIEW" POINTS OUT
IN A COLUMN TODAY HAD HILLARY
WON THE ELECTION MANY OF THE
OFFICIALS WOULD HAVE RETAINED
THEIR JOBS AND WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO COVER WHATEVER SCHEMES
THEY RAN DURING THE OBAMA
TENURE.
THEY SIMPLY COULD NOT PERMIT
TRUMP TO TAKE THE PRESIDENCY.
AND ONCE HE WAS WITHIN
STRIKING DISTANCE, I THINK
THEY GOT REALLY DESPERATE.
DESPERATE TO WRAP UP THAT
HILLARY PROBE SO MAYBE SHE
COULD TAKE THE WHITE HOUSE
LIKE THEY THOUGHT DESPERATE TO
COLLECT DIRT ON TRUMP TO
DESTROY ANY CHANCE OF THE
CANDIDACY.
IT'S A RICH IRONY THAT THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO CLAIM THAT
THEY WANT TO STOP RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS,
ADOPTED THE TACTICS OF A
TOTALITARIAN STATE.
LIKE RUSSIA.
TO STIFLE POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
AND TO SUBVERT THE ELECTION OF
DONALD TRUMP.
GIVEN ALL OF THAT, IT MADE ME
HOWL WHEN CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
THIS YESTERDAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR IS
THE KIND OF GROSSLY AUTOCRATIC
BEHAVIOR WE'D EXPECT IN A
BANANA REPUBLIC.
NOT A MATURE DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: NO, CHUCK.
BANANA REPUBLIC IS A PLACE
THAT OPPONENTS ARE SPIED UPON,
CHARGE AND UNJUSTLY
IMPRISONED.
WHAT TRUMP IS ATTEMPTING TO DO
IS EXPOSE CORRUPTION IN THE
INTEL AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVICES WHICH CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT MUST EXERCISE
THEIR OVERSIGHT OVER.
IN THE WAKE OF 9/11,
CONSERVATIVES WERE WILLING TO
TRADE PRIVACY FOR SECURITY.
WE'RE NOW BEING PHOTOGRAPHED
BY THE GOVERNMENT.
HOW MANY TIMES A DAY?
CAN'T EVEN COUNT.
OUR MONEY, AND OUR PERSONS ARE
TRACKED AT HOME AND ABROAD.
WELL, WE THE PEOPLE AND OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS SHOULD NOT
BE ENDLESSLY TRAIL AND TREATED
LIKE DANGERS TO THE STATE.
WE SHOULDN'T SPIED UPON FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
THE EVER EXPANDING
SURVEILLANCE STATE IS A THREAT
TO THE FREEDOM, AND SOME
WITHIN THE AGENCIES THINK THEY
ARE ABOVE THE LAW.
THEY ARE NOT.
THIS PRESIDENT WILL NOT BE
MANIPULATE AND HE IS INSISTING